[Music]
[Applause]
ray allen the uh hall of famer two-time
nba champ and uh we wanted to have rayon
so i could still call him the greatest
three-point shooter of all time and then
that'll probably change in a couple of
days here but uh ray allen kind enough
to join us huh
it doesn't have to change it doesn't
he'll call me that i can still call you
the greatest three-point shooter of all
time
yeah
are you the greatest three-point shooter
of all time
well that's uh certainly subjective uh
depending on who uh
who you're talking to
and and i think that's uh something that
it's interesting when we talk about that
in sports when when we talk about who we
think the greatest
of all times is when you're talking
about you know whatever quarterbacks to
you know best
basketball players
i think it's important to understand
like because we all have a different
perspective you know if you live in a
great football city or basketball city
you've seen great basketball and and
what it means to you and and the game
has certainly changed over the years so
as as i've always tried to push who i
think the greatest of all times is in
any particular sport i started to think
about and i was like but
that's to me you know it's my opinion
and you know kids today they see what
they see
based on you know social media and they
can't imagine somebody being better than
the current players that are playing
today
yeah and and i'm just looking at volume
and and really i don't even know how to
quantify this record because it's not
like barry bonds's home run record or
kareem's all-time scoring list this is
steph curry at the right time in the
right place gets an opportunity to take
8 to ten to twelve three-pointers when
you first started out you were shooting
less than four three-pointers a game if
you were starting out now
you're probably shooting eight to ten to
twelve three-pointers a game i'm
guessing
yeah most definitely uh when i first got
into the league
uh to shoot a three-pointer was like
you know it was like forbidden like
coach got mad at you he'd take you out
of the game
uh he wanted you to swing the ball throw
it into the post and so you know it
started to to evolve so i i've been
seeing all these uh these posts about
you know how many games i played and and
with my record and compared to steph and
i thought to myself i was like what what
actually does that mean uh because
everybody says oh he did this many more
games and to your point
it's it you know we shouldn't be
comparing because it has nothing to do
it doesn't say that he's a better
shooter than me i'm a better shooter
than him or we're better than reggie it
just is a number
based on the the time frame that we've
played in and how we've had an effect on
the game while we played you know
because i i would never
say that i was better than reggie uh
because reggie basically he grew a lot
of us young shooters up and we idolized
what he did and we kind of built into
our
into our practice into our routines and
to to how we play the game off of you
know the the
the example that he set and so
to to try to compare myself to him is
like you know this he's part of me and
that's kind of
i think as we start to move on every
each generation sees what the the
previous one did and they build off of
what they did and that that's what makes
the the game great and the player is
great because of who's come before them
ever lose confidence in your shot
uh
i think i've i've lost confidence in my
shot i think i know i always was going
to be able to shoot the next shot but
the thing that's most difficult is
when you when you go into a slump
it seems like you're the only one that's
trying to help you get out of that slump
because
you know the the escalator moves on
because every coach is like well he's
not shooting the ball well so we'll sit
him down and put somebody else in and so
i'm like coach i need more touches
um so it is it's certain for shooters
you have to be
able to find a way
to get to the free throw line to get the
easy layups uh to do the things that
don't put pressure on your long ball
who taught you how to shoot
well my dad was a great shooter uh he
shot right-handed and left-handed um
i always give credit to jeff lynch uh
at the base that i grew up in in edwards
air force base
i'm phil pleasant because they gave me
the fundamentals you know i still have
the video when i was shooting free
throws and it looked very terrible
and then um as i got older
um i had um
you know coach hobbs who's now at
rutgers they had a big win last night i
don't know if you've seen this yeah i
did and ron harper's son hit the game
winner virginia so congratulations to
rutgers on that on that game winner
um but coach hives was he was a guards
coach uh at uconn my freshman year and
that was his first year uconn and he
gave me these tools to work on that i
needed to get better at at shooting and
being a guard a guard in college
so
it seems like there's not one person but
there's a collection of people over the
years and i don't think any any year
that i played i thought i was good but i
was always getting pushed by somebody
from one year to the next and something
was being added
to uh to my training to workouts and you
know i was just so i soaked it up every
every year
but you start to look at around the nba
and they're guys who just can't shoot
yeah
how do you react to that when you see a
guy who can't even make you know 50 of
his free throws
well uh i've come to find out that free
throws uh it's just focus and and i
think we we don't understand how
emotional they are
and and if you don't take that emotion
that you haven't gained think about you
either just got knocked down
um
you know you hard foul like the score of
the game either down two and you got to
make these two or
you know you're up two and you gotta ice
the game
there's different scenarios that force
you to think about the free throw and if
you don't practice that
uh during practice then you're not
preparing yourself for the game
and then further
when you think about so many guys
shooting threes
how many guys
take a three when they don't need to and
they can just kind of take that one two
dribble and get the mid-range uh jump
shot
and that takes the pressure off the
three ball a time when you didn't need
it and you figure if you if you took
nine threes in the game
and you're like two for nine if you only
took six and you're two for six you know
you get those other little mid-range uh
shots going
then you might even be four for six
because now you you got yourself a
little confidence going
would you be in favor of moving the
three-point line back
uh
no i don't think moving it back uh what
if you eliminated the three-point shot
um it would definitely make the game
more methodical uh i think because then
you'd have to move around better would
it make it better
i don't think so i mean i think it'd be
more health or skeletal because the
three-point line is
it gives us a sense of spacing
uh it's a threat it gives us you know
for for uh for the defense but
i think the best way to use the
three-pointer is that it's just a threat
in your opponent you can shoot it and
then you set it up with your great
shooters and you're able to get into the
paint and do other things yeah but
there's no movement in basketball
there's a lot of stand around because of
the three-point shot and you got guys
who were shooting threes who don't
shouldn't be shooting threes ray
it sure it's your fault
yeah i agree with you and i i i don't
blame myself at all
by the way
i like to think that i i put some good
stuff out there and set a good uh tone
but i think what it boils down to is a
lot of the coaches uh when you think
about
what they accept and what they allow uh
because i've as you know in the last six
seven years i'd be watching games even
uh in the high school level i don't see
it as much in college but you see
kids shooting
between half court and three-point line
and then the coaches don't say anything
like i get it the three is more worth
more than the two but at some point
coach has to reel in certain guys and
say you know percentage-wise you know
until you get
you know work on this shot and you get
better attempts and you're more
efficient i don't want you shooting
threes i want you to get to the basket
you know we've lost a little bit of the
mid-range game and the post game for
sure well what would happen if shaq was
playing now if shaq came into the league
right now
the league it would have to change again
because shaq was just too dominant uh
i think that i believe that the the way
to go back
because what we're we're copycat leagues
so
when golden state started winning
championships
what happened was everybody had to
adjust to how they played if they wanted
to try to beat them so they sped up
their games a lot of people started
finding shoot threes and
three shooters and trying to get them to
to
to shoot the ball a lot of bigs lost
their jobs you know they moved into
benches
um
philly had a kid from duke
um
elton brand
no no no no uh you know a little bit
younger
uh big guy uh he came into the league as
they started shooting threes and then he
actually had no no place i can't think
of his name right now but
until until philly wins the nba
championship
you know that's when i think it's going
to revert back to you know a big because
you got to be down there that team right
now saying we don't really have to to to
deal with him because they're not
dominating the eastern conference and
the nba to where we need a defensive big
and a big that can score on him down low
right now we don't have that and so
until they do that and they change it
uh the game is going to be where it is
we're talking to ray allen the uh
two-time nba champ the all-time leader
in three-pointers mate are you gonna are
you have you been asked to go to the
game
in philadelphia or in indiana the next
two games for steph yeah i've talked
with i spoke with uh with the the
people with uh with the warriors and i
actually spoke with steph a little bit
uh trying to
kind of help him navigate uh this whole
process uh it's an exciting time for him
uh and i try to give him the kind of
what i was dealing with and you know
going into the game and
and everything that that led up to it
and you know i was fortunate because it
was uh i i broke the record in boston
against uh the lakers
with reggie in the building so
it's just only appropriate that uh i
find my way there by hooker by crook uh
i don't know where it's gonna be so
i got to kind of watch this thing
i don't know if you noticed but i'm
coaching myself uh gulliver prep here in
miami yeah and so we have games as well
so it's kind of like a a
tricky situation for me trying to
navigate kind of what what it is that
that happens with them but why don't you
go and heckle him ray why don't you
like put up a sign or yell out i'm the
king
because if you haven't watched anything
over the last 12 years that's not going
to bother stuff i know
who do you think would be a better
three-point shooter knowing who they are
if they started out now
kobe or michael
well i think they both were underrated
three-point shooters
when you think about they just it's like
if you could do one thing great and a
couple things great then some of the
other things get overshadowed
mike just never really had to shoot
threes because he was so good inside the
pain kobe was so good just scoring in in
general so
um if i had to say between both of them
uh you know for for
it's hard because they they both play
with their back to the basket they both
were slashes at the rim uh i just don't
think that their games were designed to
just sit out there and wait and sit
behind a three-point line but better
form better shooting form
jordan
jordan for sure
really
yeah
see this may sound strange to you i
think clay thompson
is a better stand shooter than steph is
steph is
it's like steph just creates
clay
you know get the ball maybe one dribble
or catch and shoot
is more dangerous than steph is that is
that a fair assessment in your opinion
well i wouldn't say more dangerous
because steph has the ball all the time
you know so you have to really
take that offense or that defense and
you have to contribute to and then
sometimes three guys to him and then
that's where everybody around him is
able to to to be great in their roles
but
in my comparison with with clay
clay is moving without the ball he he
can shift the defense
when he gets open everybody gets open
similar to to how i played
i believe that steph is in a lane of his
own that i don't think he has
you can say you know he and damian
lillard
uh with their ability to shoot from deep
uh and and be able to handle the ball
and get to the paint but steph gets to
the paint more than lillard does
uh but i would compare
uh clay more to myself and reggie
because we are moving without the ball
we're we're kind of on the weak side a
lot
and
we and though rip hamilton in there you
know even though rip wasn't uh he he
wasn't a big volume three-point shooter
but to be able to move the defense and
to come off pinned down the screens and
shoot in transition without touching the
ball that's a that's a real real talent
is lebron a good shooter
um
i
i say he he's a good shooter but he's
also
a field shooter the more he has the
balls in his hands you know he could
make shots he's a shot maker
yeah i don't like i don't like the form
and i don't like that he's taking all
these threes but i think that might come
as you get older that you just don't
want to drive to the hoop and take the
beating
yeah and you feel it when you get older
you feel you know you don't have that
that
that there's a
like a sponginess for lack of a better
term that your
your body
you know your your calves your ankles
you feel that sponginess when you're
younger when you get older that goes
away a little bit and so
you can you can work on jumping
just that that that much and perfect
your shooting from from outside like
well i had one of my best shooting
nights when i had uh
patellar tendonitis uh when i was
playing in milwaukee and i just managed
how to come off a screen and shoot just
by jumping a little bit and pushing the
rest away with my hands and so lebron
with his size he has so much upper body
strength though he's going to be able to
maintain shooting and shooting well but
he has to have the ball in his hands to
keep that rhythm
did you ever airball a three-pointer
i'm not i'm not going to say no because
i'm sure somebody could find something
somewhere
uh but i i always get on my kids because
i said varsity players you guys should
not be shooting air balls nowhere you
know get the ball let it hit the rim but
uh you know just like anything never i'm
never in so shooting air balls like you
didn't even have a shot of it going in
but see you got to show your kids and i
do think this is great because people
now
you know they find you again and then we
talk about you so i think even though
you're going to lose this record it's
also great to shine the spotlight on you
one more time
or at least one more time with you know
your greatness at shooting
yeah and then it goes back to reggie as
well because there's a
there's a beginning and then there's a
where we are now
and and how about an over 50 three-point
shooting contest
over 50 yeah
i mean you'd be surprised you know over
50 guys can still shoot you know reggie
can still shoot you see
reggie he's a cyclist he keeps himself
well you're not 50 yet so
uh yeah how old are you
46. okay so in over 45 three-point
shooting contest
are you the one
i mean i i like my odds okay
it's anybody over 45 for sure reggie's
still still pretty good
yeah
everybody's good like i i the one thing
that you have to remember and i tell
this to everybody that that
you know is a fan of mine or or loves
the way i shot the ball is that
for for a majority of my career i wasn't
the best player i won't say majority
before a lot of teams i played on i
wasn't the best shooter on my teams
you know
i had uh eddie house
uh great great shooter and you know was
like the microwave i think you're being
humble i think you're being oh i'm
telling you these guys it's like when
you see that every day and you're you're
pushing and they're shooting the ball
like mike miller james jones michael red
like those those types of guys they
shoot the ball so well and and when you
see them shooting in a practice they're
going at your head every single drill
and it pushes you and you just stay
challenged you stay competing and
without guys like that on my team
you know it's hard for me to think how
good i actually could could have been
without that that that example maybe i
get bird bird 65 you know he might be
able to give you one rack
he'd be able to give you one rack of
balls talk some smack
but remember bird bird didn't rely on
athleticism to shoot so it's all in his
hands and his wrists so i i do believe
he can still shoot it and you pointed
out you know that people forget this
that steph with the legs tray young with
the legs like your shot starts with your
legs and i think people forget about
that uh when you're trying to
create your jump shot there and
that's i think an underrated part of uh
great deep shooters yeah and every every
if you go back to every all-star weekend
when you look at the three-point
shootout
you listen to the commentary of of uh
the broadcast when they talk about the
guys who have a greater chance of
winning because they are more push shot
shooters
so you see they get the ball and they
just push it from here and they get to
the rack and just push and they don't
rely heavily on their lower body
and however you do it you know it
requires practice and understanding what
your release point is every time you
shoot it and you got to get it off quick
obviously playing
around great athletes so you take step
he doesn't have a lot of movement in his
lower body same thing with uh with trey
young and so they get the ball off quick
because it's to get the ball just you
just push it up there and they perfected
that so
it's not when people look at me when
they look at reggie when they look at
dale curry dale shot the ball up here so
when you look at all these different
shooters
there's everybody has a different form
mine was severely
uh reliant on you know my legs my lower
body so
you know you catch me on a shoot around
in chicago in january and february i was
having a tough go at it to start the day
because that that that united center at
the time was like it felt like 30
degrees
i'm like i can't jump everything i'm
shooting is front rim i'm like i just
don't i for so for me i had to really
get warmed up and i had to understand my
body yeah but ray
it didn't bother it didn't bother
michael jordan jumping in the united
center
nope and that's why he was great at 7 30
at night
[Laughter]
yes he was every every night at 7 30. he
was great uh hey great to talk to you
again and uh hopefully uh you get some
recognition more recognition out of this
and uh thanks for joining us ray all
right
that's that's ray allen hall of famer
two-time nba champ and uh ten-time
all-star